[Música]
liderar liderar organizaciones liderar
proyectos liderar personas liderar
incluso nuestra propia vida tareas todas
ellas relevantes especialmente la última
pero para las que quizá no todos estamos
suficientemente preparados o capacitados
en determinados momentos
sin embargo frecuentemente nos hemos
visto involucradas en ellas es un
concepto claro y conocido innovar
palabra contenida en esa y minúscula que
acompañaba a la jmas de mayúscula que
irrumpían con fuerza al inicio de este
siglo pero palabra quizá un tanto difusa
de qué hablamos cuando hablamos de
innovar hablamos de procesos
hablamos de metodologías hablamos de
nuevas tecnologías de tendencias de todo
ello a la vez o quizá de algo
radicalmente diferente y es que cuando
una palabra abarca mucho corre el riesgo
de significar muy poco
permitidme hacer un acercamiento a estos
dos conceptos desde un sector que
conozco de primera mano el sector de las
infraestructuras un sector que arrastra
bastante inercia tradicional pero que se
ha enfrentado y superado con razonable
éxito
algunos retos de forma innovadora cuando
yo empezaba en esto de la gestión de
proyectos el rol del líder de proyecto
no me corresponde a mí afortunadamente
pero ello no me impedía estar cargado de
bastantes ideas innovadoras en algún
sentido sin ningún sentido también y en
cierto modo creativas o con cierta
creatividad
hoy en día diría ingenuidad y es que en
el mundo de las infraestructuras
normalmente la idea el concepto
innovador quien crea de la nada al todo
se asocia al diseñador pero con poca
frecuencia se asocia ese concepto de
innovación al constructor que es quien
tiene que aterrizar esa idea
y materializarla y al final pasando por
unas etapas intermedias en las que nadie
ha pensado y solucionando las de una
manera que nadie antes lo ha hecho
construir es ese todo
volviendo a mi primer proyecto y
volviendo a esas ideas que solía tener
en aquel entonces cuando yo iba a
compartirlas con quien ejercía de
director del proyecto un hombre curtido
en mil batallas y terra plan is está
posiblemente
siempre me decía lo mismo otra vez otra
vez como se pone un ladrillo antonio y
antes de que yo pudiera articular
respuesta él ya tenía la suya preparada
uno encima de otro uno encima de otro
desde los romanos hasta nuestros tiempos
y hoy eh visto así razón no le faltaba
pero es que quizá la innovación no
estaba en cómo se ponían estaba en quién
o qué los ponía en el material en el que
se llevan a fabricar o seguir será así y
sólo así hasta que por algún motivo
dejemos de utilizar ladrillos y ese
motivo puede ser pues la construcción
industrializada la impresión 3d o puede
tener nombres y formas que todavía no
conocemos
y esto es solo un claro ejemplo de que
si el liderazgo no solo permite sino que
fomenta y favorece la eliminación de
determinados clichés y barreras
que nos impiden
nos aportan un filtro invisible para no
disponer de esa innovación nos va a ser
imposible crear una cultura innovadora a
grant a gran escala posiblemente a
ninguno se nos escapa de los que estamos
aquí que hoy en día en el entorno actual
la creación de valor y la toma de
decisiones no siempre va a estar
centralizada y que nosotros como líderes
no siempre vamos a tener las ideas
ganadoras ni la visión necesaria por
tanto debemos crear un entorno en el que
las ideas afloren vengan de donde vengan
y para ello debemos inspirar y ayudar a
las personas de nuestro alrededor a
trabajar y nunca mejor dicho sobre
cuatro pilares básicos
desarrollar experimentar aceptar y
cambiar
y desarrollar capacidades autónomas para
explorar ideas y es que debemos
transmitir a nuestros equipos que su
contribución es esencial y podemos y
debemos permitirles el aprendizaje pero
no es sólo en un marco cerrado y
estipulado sino intentar alinear sus
inquietudes con capacidades buenas para
nuestros negocios como pueden ser las
herramientas de ideación llámense
brainstorming business model canvas o
incluso la asistencia de eventos que
nada tengan que ver con nuestro entorno
en definitiva todo aquello que les ayude
a pensar de una forma diferente y
disruptiva pero más importante si cabe
es permitir tiempo para que ese
aprendizaje sea puesto en práctica para
que las ideas afloren porque si no de
nada servirá ese aprendizaje si no les
permitimos el tiempo necesario para
ponerlo en práctica y eso me lleva al
segundo punto experimentar generar ideas
compartir ideas está muy bien pero hay
que pensar en
planes de acción para llevarlas a cabo
cómo se implementan en nuestro marco
concreto y al final nos daremos cuenta
que muchas fracasan pero también que
muchas tienen éxito con las que fracasan
no crucifiquemos a quien lleva a cabo el
experimento porque eso nos lleva al
punto 3 aceptar el fallo necesitamos
líderes que no tengan miedo a fracasar
que no tengan miedo a cometer errores ni
a que otros los cometan y sobre todo y
principal que sepan aprender de esos
errores y al final también es bueno
aceptar esos errores pero también
celebrar lo que lo que funcione porque
eso nos permitirá al final crear una
cultura en la que podemos fallar sin sin
miedo y podemos celebrar lo que funciona
por último cambiar cambiar la cultura de
control por una cultura de compromiso
con la cultura de control sólo
controlamos lo que ya conocemos y yo nos
lleva a aplicar fórmulas de manual para
poder medir las fácilmente sin embargo
con una cultura de compromiso nos va a
permitir enfrentar enfrentarnos a los
obstáculos sin miedo una métrica sin
miedo a sar a ser evaluados y eso va a
permitir soluciones que antes no estaban
no estaban pensadas al final con ello
con ese compromiso generaremos un
vínculo más fuerte en el equipo y es que
está en nuestra mano abandonar la
complacencia que nos lleva a perpetuar
comportamientos que tenemos ya
interiorizado es en forma de hábitos y
rutinas y si de verdad queremos
innovación dejemos de hacer lo que nos
previene de conseguirla bajo mi punto de
vista tenemos un problema de memoria
porque olvidamos con relativa facilidad
situaciones del pasado que que
solventamos de una forma innovadora pero
que conviven con algo mucho más poderoso
en nuestro presente el miedo natural a
lo nuevo
como suelo decir en forma de metáfora
profesional nosotros somos el puente
entre el presente y el futuro por tanto
y para que siga en pie no dejemos nunca
de construirlo
[Aplausos]